[Music]
the family of giants you work for is
throwing a fancy dinner party and they
all want to look their best but there's
a problem the elder Giants favorite
shirt is wrinkled to fix it you'll need
to power up the giant iron the iron
needs two giant batteries to work you
just had for working ones and four dead
ones in separate piles but it looks like
the baby giant mixed them all up you
need to get the iron working and press
the giant shirt fast or you'll end up
being the main course tonight how can
you test the batteries so that you're
guaranteed to get a working pair in
seven tries or less
you could of course take all eight
batteries and begin testing the 28
possible combinations you might get
lucky within the first few tries but if
you don't moving the giant batteries
that many times will take way too long
you can't rely on luck
you need to assume the worst possibility
and plan accordingly
however you don't actually need to test
every possible combination remember
there are four good batteries in total
meaning that any pile of six you choose
will have at least two good batteries in
it that doesn't help you right away
since testing all six batteries could
still take as many as 15 tries but it
does give you a clue to the solution
dividing the batteries into smaller
subsets narrows down the possible
results so instead of six batteries
let's take any three this group has a
total of three possible combinations
since both batteries have to be working
for the iron to power up a single
failure can't tell you whether both
batteries are dead or just one but if
all three combinations fail then you'll
know this group has either one good
battery or none at all now you can set
those three aside and repeat the process
for another three batteries you might
get a match but if every combination
fails again you'll know this set can
have no more than one good battery that
would leave only two batteries untried
since there are four good batteries in
total and you've only accounted for two
so far both of these remaining ones must
be good dividing the batteries into sets
of three three and two is guaranteed to
get a working result in seven tries or
less no matter what order you test the
piles in with no time to spare the ion
comes to life and you managed to get the
shirt flawlessly ironed the pleased
elder and his family show up to the
party dressed to the nines well almost
here's today's bonus riddle
again there are eight batteries for
working and for dead a new model of the
giant iron has six battery slots but it
only requires four workin batteries to
run how many tries do you need this time
to get the iron working this riddle and
bonus riddle come courtesy of our
sponsor brilliant brilliant helps you
develop your joy of learning by
cultivating your curiosity helping you
understand how concepts fit together and
providing you with different ways of
interpreting a scenario try them out at
brilliant org slash Ted ed and the first
eight hundred thirty three of you to use
that link will get a twenty percent
discount off the annual subscription